Tên Rồi Tên, ngày 1 sót thằng thư đưa tin, và kết thang đã đưa ra để sốt 2 se đoạn,
nhằm chấm rất tình chẳng thủ định dưới vệ yvràn trong đó rất đoạn đoạn là lệ yvràn như lập tức để mở lại ở bên hoặc ngốc.
Khi tế theo là một thời thận quanh dẹn trong phòng nguyên lâm đến 20 ngày.
Hôm cuộc này tạm gọi là thời thận ít là mạng, đưa cho là đại đoạn đoạn đoạn lịch cho đoạn linh tục thông qua các tình ngoại giao của Pakistan.
Phá ký stand đã liên hệ vì các quan chức thấp cao của Mỹ và Iran bao gồm pháu tổng thống Mỹ trên event,
và ngoại trường ít Ràn Abbas Arachin.
Theo ngồn tiền Rồi Tên, thật thận dài hạn của tệ bao gồm cám kết của Iran về không phát triển bố kiện nhận đoạn là việc nối lòng trường phát.
Tuy nhiên, một con trường ít Ràn trường biết, Tên Ràn trưa sẵn sàng chức nhận đoạn đoạn thời phản đối các xác liên quan để việc mở lại yêu biển thông ốc.
Đại diễn bộ mọi người Sở Iran, Sở Mèo, Bà Kháy, Ngay Mung, Sò thắng tư nhấn mạnh, nước này đứng sử dựa con khổ dây ăn dựa trị lỗi của gia.
Đồng thời cho sẵn sàng chức nhận những điều kiện liên quan đến truy trình hạp nhân, họ quyền kiểm soát tuyến hành hại trường lợp.
Trúc khi đau tổng thống Mỹ đôi năng trăm tích tục được sát tạnh bao gương sẵn.
Eo Kowi Ràn mở lại yêu biển hông ốc. Đồng thời không loại trường khả năng hành động cuộc sử.
Con hỗ lực trung dàng từ bà kistan thủy nghĩ và ai tập và nâng đều tục đầy, sông tếm trình đàn phản đều đầy giá là con nhiều trường hại.